good morning heck it's tuesday well
that's a curious development thank you
to everyone who has pre-ordered the
anthropocene reviewed book
behind me are just over 150 000 sheets
of paper which look like
this only they haven't been signed yet
i'm going to sign all those sheets to
make sure that every pre-order of the
american and canadian edition is
autographed as well as every copy of the
first printing of the book this is a
little more than i was expecting but i
am delighted and only a smidge
intimidated you know what let's go
outside
i've really enjoyed walking lately and
just letting my thoughts wander around
as i wander around like this morning i'm
thinking about this wallace stevens poem
that begins
20 men crossing a bridge into a village
is 20 men crossing 20 bridges into 20
villages
the bridge is different to each of us as
is the village beyond
i guess i'm thinking about this poem
because i'm remembering a walk i took
10 years ago with my friend esther as
part of her make a wish she'd gathered
some of her nerdfighter friends and
invited me to be there
as well and so we were all outside
together on our way to get some gelato
which necessitated crossing a bridge
the bridge had a grated floor so that
you could see through to the teeming
river below and i've never been super
enthusiastic
about heights or for that matter bridges
and esther
whose empathy dials were always turned
up to 11
noticed there was something wrong she
told me that we were almost across the
bridge
and that i could take over pushing her
wheelchair if i wanted something to hang
on to
she knew my bridge was different from
hers
and so the true observation is never
this bridge is terrifying
instead the only thing you can say with
any certainty is
my bridge is terrifying how about yours
and then this is the real trick of
living on a planet that contains many
other human souls that are as valuable
and multitudinous as your own
you must find a way to really listen to
this other person's answer
and to believe in their experience as
fully as we believe
in our own today i am walking in the
woods in precisely the same place where
i was walking in the woods last week
but it's a completely different walk for
one thing
the world was different last week the
leaves were greener
the wind milder now the leaves are
starting to fall
and it's cold but the walk is also
different because
the person taking it has changed
last week i felt the dread encroaching
the prospect of winter not just a fact
but also a threat this week the
weather's worse
and i'm better why who knows
these days i barely know how i am let
alone
why i am and so i like this walk in the
woods or
any outdoor experience that is
repeatable in part
because it isn't actually repeatable
being on the same path in the same woods
helps me remember
that it is never quite the same woods
and also helps me to remember
that how i currently am is just not
how i will always be tomorrow a
different me
will take a different walk in different
woods
even if the gps says the route was
identical
as i walk an imprecise loop through the
woods my thoughts circle back to esther
esther's been gone now for over 10 years
but her thoughtfulness and kindness
still help me
they still hold me together i use them
to remind me that
your bridge may be scary even if mine
isn't
and so often i return to that memory
and tell myself that i'm almost across
the bridge
and that i can hold on to something if i
need to
hank i'll see you on friday